hi guys today I'm here with Nikki limo
and we just recorded an episode of not
too deep and it was hilarious really fun
it was super fun I learned so much and
almost nothing about Nikki yes
so on the surface level things were
there yeah all the things we really want
to know about each other so go over to
SoundCloud or iTunes and go listen to
the full podcast but while she was here
I thought it would be fun for us to a
challenge my anxiety levels just rising
and rising because I want I didn't even
tell her that this is the challenge I
wanted to do and so she got here it was
like by the way I would just UK with
electrocution yeah yeah it's the shock
ball challenge which a lot of people
have done on YouTube
and I can't even like watch those videos
because it's yeah he's so anxious way to
pick a challenge we both have crazy
anxieties yeah so he's watching two
girls of two girls one panic attack is
what you're watching so here's how it's
gonna work
in this hat we have a bunch of note
cards that have different categories on
them and so we'll choose a category and
then we have two like hot potato go back
and forth saying something that's in
that category for instance colors
it'd be like blue and then I hand her
the ball and she says the color and we
go back and forth until one of us gets
shocked because this is on a random
timer of shocking people haha
please I don't know I don't know someone
sat at home thinking of this idea they
took at the shark tank and here we are
today depending on how much it hurts
emotionally and physically it's gonna be
the first person that gets shocked three
times is the loser okay but really there
are no winners in this game
okay so before we turn this on let's
pick a category
okay okay I'll let you pick oh thank you
you're welcome
I've already made you do so many
terrible things colors Oh colors I'd
like I think they're all colors though
as soon as this goes on the games begin
oh god yeah II just rose like my
shoulders are gonna be up to my forehead
by they'll be ready ready all right dawn
okay blue
red orange magenta yellow four full
round cream black mother-of-pearl okay
Oh what I felt like you saw heard of it
uh I got the bulk of it okay
so we'll say that's one for me that
wasn't as bad as I thought I wasn't as
bad because my anxiety is so high that I
think it's like deflating the actual
pain that might be coming yes I think so
it's actually on our side anxiety is for
once watch once it's on it's just
continuously randomly shocked okay I'll
wait for the light to buzz again we'll
choose a new category for the next round
hello games that kids play oh man what
the what no wait for it to shock it's
the couch and I'm okay there goes and
whoop hey buddy hey you're done like no
way here we go
hopscotch Oh Lucy the one um monopolies
jump rope
do playground Oh Red Rover oh my god
I think the anticipation is more hurts
more than the actual show and also I
just drooled all over my body's like
shaking because I'm so not to breathe
when I kinds of liquids kinds of liquids
wedding okay here we go
what was the types of liquids types of
look back up urine um milk um chocolate
milk oh shut up
it's protein shake Oh patty a smoothie
copy
orange juice um um last or me I don't
know this last category my jaw shaking
I'm so scared
I'm also a very cold person oh yeah yeah
so there's a lot of feelings happening
real-time okay
vegetables is this category okay carrots
broccoli uh lettuce spinach tomatoes
tails
I'm sorry beats Kennedys I'm Jacob ah oh
my baby no no this is officially the
last okay cuz we're tied 2-2 yeah no I
don't know what's winning and what's
losing at this point but this is gonna
be the last category the fourth quarter
okay
aaah-choo aaah-choo animals with tails
what don't they all have them I thought
only I was like only dogs have tails dog
Bosh um kangaroo zebra donkey neither
ass of course a cat elephant
um tiger dragon Oh leopard then lion
Jaguar Gina a lip fudge well Nikki I'm
sorry to say that you are the loser man
but I really real the loser as well I
really don't feel like I won oh thank
you for dealing with that it was fun
actually my boyfriend side town so
that's like the most stimulation I've
got well I appreciate you putting up
with all of it and make sure you go
check out Nicky's channel is Nikki limo
and then she's a vlog Channel it's just
Nikki's just Nikki and go check out the
podcast which was really fun really fun
on Soundcloud and really liked it it's
you liked it more than we liked this
game that yes but all my social medias
are at Nikki limo except Facebook is
official Nikki limo
great yeah Jaime go find her
this was fun I don't know do you have a
food that you would do terrible things
to get oh I thought you were gonna say
terrible things to and I was like no it
is it's a different part yes it's called
weird fetishes with grace Helbig